I have two stories for you today about
French president Emmanuel macron one is
more serious the other one is just sort
of funny let's start with the serious
one I've spoken before about how dealing
with Donald Trump is sort of like
dealing with a petulant child sometimes
you have to be strict with them
sometimes you have to humor them
sometimes you have to ignore them
altogether and do the adult stuff when
they're distracted or not in the room
and Emmanuel macron has used some
toddler level reverse psychology to
completely get Donald Trump to change
his public tune on NATO Donald Trump as
you might know has been denouncing NATO
attacking NATO criticizing NATO for a
very long time NATO is a treaty it
includes 29 countries mostly for shared
military defense support Trump is of
course in the UK for meetings the for a
NATO summit and there have been some
really good articles including one in
The Washington Post about how a lot of
care is being taken to prevent Donald
Trump from ruining anything and this
includes inviting Trump to dinner at
Buckingham Palace and some other
festivities private meetings with
different world leaders all sorts of
different stuff to try to prevent Donald
Trump from ruining the entire thing so
Emmanuel macron the French president
took a bit of a different approach the
French President started last month
being a little critical himself of NATO
in a pretty narrow way talking about the
brain death of NATO talking about issues
with NATO but at no point is it really
in question that Francis of course a
strong NATO ally partner and supporter
but word got to trump hey Emmanuel
macron is saying these things so what is
Donald Trump do well of course he says
no no no McCrone is wrong yesterday
Donald Trump declared that NATO serves a
great purpose pushing back against
McCrone saying that McCrone is wrong and
France really needs NATO quote from
Donald Trump
NATO serves a great purpose and I hear
that president McCrone said NATO is a
brain-dead I think that's very insulting
to a lot of different forces when you
make a statement like that that is a
very very nasty statement 228 including
them 28 countries check this out
he
went further talking about how France
needs NATO look at this clip
nobody needs data more than France you
just look back over the last long period
of time
nobody needs negative other friends and
frankly the one that benefits really the
least is the United States we benefit
the least we're helping Europe Europe
unites and they go against a common foe
that maybe it may not be a foe can tell
you that but there are other phones out
there also but I think nobody needs it
more than France and that's why I think
that when friends makes a statement like
they made about NATO that's a very
dangerous for them this is how you
manipulate kids right for years world
leaders have been struggling how do we
get Trump to stop attacking NATO how do
we get the President of the United
States to stop undermining NATO incomes
the French president makes one comment
about hey here's an issue with NATO and
next thing you know Trump sees the
opportunity to criticize a European
leader and in he goes defending NATO
more strongly than he arguably has ever
done during his entire presidency this
is the type of reverse psychology that
parents use on toddlers in general when
a kid is like 4 or 5 or you know maybe 6
years old this type of reverse
psychology stops working because it's
too transparent and the kid learns what
it is that you're trying to do on Donald
Trump it still works brilliantly
executed by Emmanuel macron European
leaders all say NATO is good NATO is
good
so Trump has to say no no no NATO is bad
McCrone slips in NATO is sort of maybe
not that great in this one specific way
and all of a sudden a flaw switch flips
I was about to say a flip switches a
switch flips and NATO is good for Donald
Trump nicely done by Emmanuel macron and
now let's get on to the funnier Trump
McCrone story from yesterday before you
go on to the next video please hit
subscribe and like we are trying to
figure
what this will do for helping us in
YouTube's algorithm I will report back
to you but please before you go onto the
next video please subscribe to our
channel and hit that like button thank
you